et pour en parler marine calme est
juriste et président de l'association
wild légal est avec nous en direct sur
rt france marine calmette merci de
répondre à nos questions alors on en
parlait de cette émotion mondiale
l'année dernière devant ces images d'un
sans dire en amazonie pourtant cette
année encore plus de départs de feux ont
été recensés dans le poumon de la
planète alors comment l'expliquez est ce
que c'est une surprise au fond non ça
absolument pas une surprise
on a été les causes sont les mêmes que
l'année dernière c'est à dire comme ça a
été très bien montré dans la vidéo
installés plus d'agriculteurs ou
d'éleveurs sur ses terres qui sont
d'abord des friches et puis brûlé et
donc évidemment puisque la consommation
mondiale ne s'est pas régulier il ya
aucune raison finalement que c'est
déforestation cesse ou s'atténue mais
c'est ces agriculteurs qui viennent
s'installer dans la forêt amazonienne
ils ont des autorisations alors
finalement il n'y a pas de je dirais de
restriction particulière pour ce type
d'activité alors il ya eu soit disant un
moratoire qui a été lancé par james
cenach au le président mais évidemment
c'est en fait le problème c'est que ces
déforestation et sont majoritairement
illégal donc évidemment ces agriculteurs
ces éleveurs ne vont pas se tenir à des
interdictions qui viendraient de la part
de l'état donc c'est un peu un écran de
fumée
finalement pour pour cacher le fait que
tout simplement on n'agit pas
concrètement contre ces défis
arrestations illégales mais finalement
est-ce que le confinement n'a pas permis
à ses agriculteurs illégaux et bien à
eux d'agir en toute impunité
si complètement d'ailleurs on constate
un le nombre de contrôles a énormément
diminué c'est à dire que finalement ils
ont libre cours dans l'activité pour
continuer à brûler et donc ça c'est
extrêmement grave c'est ce que dénoncent
les associations mais aussi nous au
niveau de l'union européenne et au
niveau de la france il faut qu'on agisse
puisqu'on a une part de responsabilité
énorme dans cette déforestation
étant donné notre consommation et notre
dépendance finalement aux importations
aux origines du brésil je pense au soja
au boeuf notamment qui font que nous
devons prendre notre part de
responsabilités et agir et mettre en
place des processus qui me permettent de
réguler justement cette déforestation la
france effectivement un concernés
notamment en guyane vous parliez de
mesures à prendre
quelles mesures concrètes aujourd'hui la
france pourrait-elle prendre par exemple
alors si on était totalement cohérent
évidemment il faudrait mettre un terme
immédiat aux importations de soja ou de
boeuf qui sont directement la cause la
plus évidente de cette déforestation
malheureusement on est dépendant on sait
on s'est bloqué dans cette situation de
dépendance vis-à-vis notamment du soja
la france importe 61% de son soja
d'origine précis guen et et on le voit
malheureusement on a perdu une part de
notre souveraineté dans cette relation
de dépendance
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire plutôt mettre un plat
justement une coopération entre les
agriculteurs qui sont aussi dépendants
de leurs terres là bas au brésil
et puis nos importations ici en france
c'est à dire mettre en place des
mécanismes de solidarité qui permettent
d'assurer que là bas les terres ne soit
plus déforester qu'elles soient
entretenus dans des conditions
écologiquement viables durable et qu en
france on puisse retrouver la main aussi
sur notre souveraineté alimentaire ne
regrettait de production de protéines
pour qu'on soit moins dépendant
justement de sept de ses importations
massives de soja brésilien alors vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure le président
brésilien il a déclaré la semaine
dernière que je cite cette histoire sur
l'amazone i qui brûle dans le feu est un
mensonge alors contre comment comprenez
vous cette posture du président
brésilien
il applique son programme ont tout
simplement il a été élu aussi en grande
partie pour son discours absolument
contraires à la protection de l'amazonie
c'est à dire qu'il envoyait un message
clair en fait politique disant
l'agriculture passe avant tout
finalement les propriétaires terriens
finalement passe avant la protection de
l'environnement donc il applique son
programme jusqu'à demain en revanche
c'est notre rôle en tant que membres la
communauté internationale et puis aussi
de la part des ong de continuer à
alerter et malheureusement il n'y a rien
à attendre de ce président en matière
écologique c'est évident par contre le
rôle de la communauté internationale
elle c'est de ne pas fermer les yeux
justement de ne pas continuer à tolérer
ce genre de comportement on le voit
d'ailleurs quand des messages politiques
forts sont émis à l'encontre de chaleur
wolson a reçu retrouve finalement forcer
à agir et il y à de nombreuses actions
en cours contre contre le président
contre c'est la politique qui est mis en
place
je pense notamment à deux recours qui
ont été déposées auprès de la cour
pénale internationale et qui pour crimes
de génocide et qui dénonce très
clairement l'impact à la fois le lien
entre la déforestation et l'impact sur
les droits des populations autochtones
qui sont directement les premières
victimes en fait de cette politique mis
en place sur le territoire
merci beaucoup marine calme est d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes juriste présidente de
l'association wild liga